provide great value to your customers
when you provide great value it makes it
easy to do business with you it makes it
easy to say yes to buy more to pass
referrals onto you
make sure you're taking every step you
can
to provide real value
to the people who are paying you
it's not that hard i wanted to share a
great example
so odesk is a company that i love it
helps you find outsourced workers for
your business and so i have one worker
for me named gretchen who's does some of
my marketing she's based in the
philippines and one of the biggest
challenges that people who hire remotely
face
is
the people go offline
you're working well on a project maybe
you've worked together for a couple of
months and then the person just goes
m.i.a they're gone like where is this
person i have an important project and
they're gone they're not responding to
emails they're nowhere to be found
this sucks
and if you hire through a company like
odesk then you don't just blame the
worker you also play modest and i know
entrepreneurs who are friends of mine
who
refuse to hire an odesk now because they
had one bad experience and they blame
odes for it
it's not that their hiring practices
were crappy
right or that maybe just hired the wrong
person but they blame odes so that's
that's the challenge
for you as an entrepreneur there are
things that are outside your control
that if customers have a bad experience
with you they're going to blame you
i don't care if a typhoon hits your
company they're still going to blame you
and think that you are unreliable so
it's clearly explaining to customers
what's going on and providing value so
odesk back to my odessa story a great
example that came in oda sent me an
email
and it started with your freelancer may
be affected
by typhoon in the philippines and they
sent this whole email
uh basically saying that a big typhoon
hit the philippines and people are
having a hard time with their power and
electrical outages
and you may not hear from your worker
because they know i've hired somebody in
the philippines
and they say you may not hear from them
or they may have a hard time connecting
to you
this is huge value
because i don't follow what's happened
in the philippines how would i know if
there was a typhoon part of my daily
life is not going to check the weather
in the philippines
so they alerted me to a really important
situation where if i didn't hear from my
person for a week
it's not because they don't care they
just can't get internet because nothing
has happened in the philippines
it's not their fault but i would blame
them right if i didn't know this was
happening i would blame them
not hire them back
and i would blame odesk
having these crappy contractors i'm not
going to go with them again why would i
do that what a waste of time
meanwhile it's a force that is
completely outside
anybody's control
so it's a great value add from odesk
think about what else you could do for
your business think about the value that
you can provide and maybe it's just
something that's as clear as
communicating what's going on especially
when factors are outside your control
communicate that so your customers and
prospects understand what's going on and
they don't blame
you
so congrats to odess great job for all
your entrepreneurs out there it's time
to step up your game and offer more
value to your customers
believe
for those of you watching thumbs up
below if you liked the video i love
seeing those come in so thank you so
much and i want to hear from you please
leave a comment underneath let me know
what you think if you have a question
put it down there i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon